لا يقوى هذا الرجل الا على البكاء
نجا من الزلزال المدمر
زوجته وابنتاه كنا اقل حظا
ومثل عائلته في جنديرس في حلب جثث اخرى
لضحايا قضوا تحت انقاض منازلهم
على مدار الساعه يتواصلوا عمليات البحث عن
المفقود تحت الانقاض حتى ساعات متاخره من
الليل
مفقودون يتبين مصيرهم ساعه بعد اخرى امام
اعين اقاربهم طلعوا الصبح خمسه من اقربائه
وهلا
طلعوا 3 اشخاص من عيله وحده كمان
تحت الانقاذ ثمان اشخاص لساته موجود لحد
الان تحت الانقاذ والله ناطرين انه ان شاء
الله
بجهود الدفاع المدني والاخوه المدنيين
معهم انه ان شاء الله بيطلعوا لنا اياهم
اما الناجون فيتناوبون بين المساعده في
الانقاذ وبين قسط راحه ودف
ما لم تدمره الحرب في سوريا دمره الزلزال
فزاد السوريين بؤسا والما
مئه الضحايا وعشره العائلات يرقدون تحت
الركام ومدينه باتت ملامحها اشبه بالاطلال
وفي البال ذكريات ووجع
في درجات حراره تلامس الصفر ووسط ظلام
دامس يواصل الاهالي والدفاع المدني عمليات
البحث عن الناجين تحت الانقاض كما يامرون
وصول المساعدات العاجله عمر حلبي الجزيره
من ناحيه جنديرس ريف حلب